in this video i challenged jeremy
my fresh art of film school intern
to throw every single rule that
he's just learned out the window
to prove that most rules in filmmaking are
made to be broken morning baby see you later
so as you can see i'm in new york city i've just
moved to the states to open up a joe which is
my production company back at home in
cape town but i'm opening up another one
in los angeles not here not in 368
but that's a story for another time
right now in new york city i find myself with
a little bit or it's it's a pretty big dilemma
you see i left something really
important back at home in cape town
jeremy hey what's up dude
did i by any chance leave
the big insta 360 camera there that new
one that came in a box i have no idea
okay you found it yeah i got
it it's sitting in the room
okay i've got to make a video with this camera
uh you're gonna have to make this video okay
um okay uh let me think i'll phone you
in five minutes okay cool yeah okay
hey dude okay so yes what you're gonna do
so i want you to go over to my bookshelf
and get a notepad that says breaking the law
and your first task as my intern is to break
every law and cinematography that i've
written in all by using the insta360 one rs
one inch 360 camera wow that's a mouthful
but yes all by using that make me proud
while jeremy learns to unlearn
everything that he learned
at film school or like didn't learn at
film school i'm going to in the meantime
show you a montage i made when i was back
in cape town of this beast of a 360 camera
where'd you next alex los angeles
yeah welcome to l.a bruh sure
okay i've just arrived in alley to summarize
because i obviously don't have this camera
i've challenged jeremy to test that he or anyone
with minimal filmmaking experience like actual
filmic not not film school experience can make
something great with just a little bit of effort
and minimal gear you've probably heard of a
filmmaking term known as the 180 degree rule
basically it means that the camera should
never cross the imaginary line between
subjects in a scene this can confuse the
audience which is definitely considered wrong
can you see me seeing you do you understand
everything about the 180 degree line yeah i
think so okay cool so now with this knowledge
what i want you to do is break that rule
shoot something doesn't matter what it is just
needs to be creative cut it and then call me and
show me and let's take it from there cool yeah i'm
good we got this don't let us down we got to make
insta360 proud but i believe in you i can't wait
to see what you've done me neither that gives me
no hope okay cool i think this is all i'm gonna
need can you help me film this video yeah sure
cool and everybody dances we are going to try
to recreate that shot from rules of attraction
okay are you guys ready shank incredible oh
it should be fine it'll like stabilize on post
yeah i think we got it jeremy's calling
yeah i got something to show you let's
see it i've already finished editing it put it
together cool cool play it play play it yeah hey
how's it going um have you seen my sandwich what
time i had a sandwich in the fridge with my name
on it and uh it seems to be gone i haven't seen
anything like that cool let me know if it turns up
hey man dude how the [__] did you do
that you like it yeah bro well done thanks
okay move on to the next one cool i'll call
you back when i'm done he's doing good lore
2 expensive looking shots need expensive gear in
many of my previous videos i tend to prove that
you don't necessarily need the best gear to tell
your story okay action for this second challenge
jeremy is also going to have to prove this
theory by achieving a cinematic jib or crane shot
without a jib or a crane it's golden hour it
looks incredible and cut let's see how that looks
jeremy said he's about a call to show me the
second law being broken high expectations yeah
hey bro uh i think i think i broke the
second rule okay yeah erica you ready
what dude you're killing this you think so that
looked so good okay dope dude um this is actually
working out pretty well i'm just about to jump on
a plane to san francisco and when i get there i
want to see the third rule being broken okay cool
okay perfect bree i'll catch you now cheers peace
off to san fran
so good to see you bro law three the dolly zoom
is not just used for tension it's the type of shot
where the camera zooms opposite to its movement
it's usually used to inside fear or amplify
a character's internal realization but jeremy is
going to use this technique not to add tension
but rather to make something look far more
epic so i'm putting this thing nice and low
there it is there's the camera
we're sitting at about 30 kilometers an hour
oh my god jason got so close to the car i
think that was a good take let's see how the
see how the footage looks it's now 10 to 1
a.m in san francisco and jeremy's calling
yes yo dude how's san francisco dude how's
the duddy's shot let me show you quick
i'm gonna go landscape it's upside down okay we
counter rotating our rotate okay you ready good
looks like some james bun [__] amazing thanks
dude i think that's everything i think i think
i've done all of it all of what i think i've
i've broken all the rules but you have broken one
hundredth of the rules but you've passed we have
a long journey ahead there jesus you're doing good
that's that though okay that's the wrap how do you
feel tired we're good again perfectly dude thanks
so much peace cheers dude i think he was stoked
the point here is that as filmmakers limitations
can be the fuel to our out-the-box thinking
to our creativity and with tools like this
there is no box there's no 16x9 frame that
we are confined to but rather an infinite
canvas for your story to be told in the most
beautifully authentic and aesthetic way possible
and yeah that's all from me this week thank you
so much to jeremy and the team for pulling us
off you guys did incredibly and i'm blown away
by your talent then again i don't know if it's
your talent or if it's the camera you as the
audience tell me what do you think and obviously
thank you brew for watching for commenting and for
subscribing and turning that notifications bell on
other than that don't forget you're
awesome bru and i'll see you next week
you forgot perfectly